Hey, and in this video, we're gonna have a look
at something called ChatGPT Memory.
This basically allows ChatGPT to store previous information
from your recorded chat history sessions.
You can prompt memory as well.
So we're gonna go into the top left, go to GPT-4o,
and then what I'm gonna do is say,
remember that my name is James.
And what you'll see is that ChatGPT is actually gonna say
memory created or memory updated,
and ChatGPT is able to then figure out
that there's a memory here.
After clicking on Manage Memories,
you can see all of the memories that appear,
and you can also delete memories as well.
So I could delete that, you know,
ChatGPT knows that my name is James.
Now, why memory is so powerful is because we could go
to a new conversation and say, what is my name?
And it knows that my name is James.
And this is really good because this basically means
we can store or tell ChatGPT to store relevant information
about our business, about our personal context,
and then that information is going to be dynamically
injected into the prompt and make the chat
and the responses much more tailored to you
and your current situation.
So remember, you can access your memories
by creating a memory.
You can also access your memories
if you go to the top right.
Go to Settings, and then once you're in Settings,
click on Personalization, and then go to Manage,
and you'll see all of your memories here.
You can clear all memories,
or you can clear a single memory,
and then over time, you will accumulate more memories.
The last thing I wanna show you when it comes to memories
is how to explicitly inject memories into ChatGPT,
and that's just through prompting.
So for example, I could say I want you to remember
that my name is James Phoenix.
And then what we're basically doing to ChatGPT
is explicitly injecting memories
that are then gonna be saved.
So you don't necessarily have to wait for ChatGPT
to collect memories about what you want it
to know all the time.
You could just keep asking ChatGPT to add memories
or update existing memories.
You could say, can you update my age
based on the 13th of September 1992?
So you can specifically update memories as well,
or delete memories by just prompting
and talking to ChatGPT.
I find this is a really great way
when I've had a very in-depth conversation
or I want to frame all of the conversations
for ChatGPT going forward with specific memories.
That's when I'll explicitly add these in
so that they're always present.